hallo willkommen zu tag 3 und damit dem
großen finale des tik tok projekt das
große finale desktop projekt als ihr
euch fragt wer ich bin der damit von
morgen und was ich mache kommentiere man
selber bisher unveröffentlichtes tik tok
video weil es verflixt noch mal
unterhaltsam war und ich dachte
vielleicht hitziger in den ersten beiden
tagen haben wir sind circa 20 ticks
produziert davon haben es nur zehn
online geschafft wenn ihr jetzt
überhaupt nicht wissen worüber ich
spreche dann checkt auf jeden fall hier
oben das erste video ab indem ich tag
eins und zwei bedienen und jetzt kommt
es aber dazu dass ich euch endlich sagen
kann wie viele views und wieviel likes
und wie viel das alles über 48 stunden
gezogen
endlich kann ich euch sagen wieviel
likes und wieviel views das gezogene
also mit vier stunden aufwand und zirka
vier tagen in denen die tech talks
zeiten wie diesen zu ziehen haben wir
unfassbare 931 1931 1000 aufrufe
generiert was völlig crazy ist was
niemals mit so wenig aufwand auf irgend
eine andere plattform funktionieren
würde
darüber habe ich aber schon im ersten
video gesprochen also bestellt euch das
135000 likes was völlig verrückt ist und
6500 abonnenten ist es möglich auf tik
tok in kurzer zeit erfolgreich zu werden
ja definitiv
ja du hast auch im video mit max und
rewe gemacht wow jetzt ist die frage wie
weit kann man das treiben wie weit
können wir jetzt in einem tag das ganze
noch ausbauen wenn wir uns vollkommen
darauf fokussieren nur mit dem trend zu
gehen und alles zu machen was gerade gut
auf tik tok funktionieren und vielleicht
merken wir dann dass es gar nicht so
schlau ist mit den trends zu gehen und
einfach nur irgendwo mitläufer zu sein
sondern dass es schlauer ist eigene
konzepte zu entwickeln
vielleicht merken wir dass es schlauer
ist eigene kreativität einzubringen so
jetzt ist die frage was können wir am
dritten tag noch anders machen als in
den ersten beiden tagen und ist es
möglich diesen hype von den ersten
beiden tagen nochmal zu reproduzieren
nein
[Musik]
nein das werden wir jetzt einen timer
auf anderthalb stunden stellen und
probieren in diesen anderthalb stunden
so viele tipps wie es geht nachzustellen
die gerade im trend
ja viel spaß ist eine sache hatte ich
noch vergessen bleibt auf jeden fall bis
zum ende dran weil dann gibt es ein
fazit von mir ein fahrrad sind über tik
tok von mir
das müsst ihr sehen so überspringen wenn
man den ganzen tag wo ich dann gestern
die talks erstellt haben weil das waren
wirklich nur anderthalb stunden wo ich
hier vom fans darum stand um in mein
handy gesprochen habe warum war das
jetzt weniger erfolgreich als das was
sie in den ersten beiden tagen gemacht
hat und das war erst der anfang ja meine
dix ganz einfach sind die antwort darauf
warum es nicht funktioniert hat ist zwar
unlustig nichts krasses passieren das
ist der grund dafür warum sachen einfach
nicht gut ankommen im internet es geht
ja im endeffekt darum leute zu
unterhalten wenn man das nicht schafft
dann funktioniert das auch nicht schon
wieder vergessen
ich war da ich schwierigkeiten habe auf
abruf lustig zu sein ist tik tok
vielleicht auch einfach nicht die
richtige plattform für mich in den
ersten beiden tagen habe ich noch
hinbekommen tech talks zu machen die ein
bisschen originell waren und vielleicht
auch ein paar leute unterhalten haben
plus dieses erste tik tok von max und
drehen wie was gut performt hat ein
relativ leichter start und 34 stück
danach haben auch noch mal richtig gut
angezogen jetzt war zum einen dieses max
und rewilding nicht mehr da diese tecdax
waren unfassbar unterhaltsam und einfach
schlecht also wirklich schlecht
[Musik]
und genau deswegen funktioniert das
nicht die plattform sind darauf
ausgelegt dass den leuten zeug
ausgespielt wird was sie auf der
plattform hält ohne dass sie denken
motto ist ja voll scheiße und ich gehe
lieber wieder zu instagram oder so also
im prinzip läuft das so man letzten tick
tock das wird an 50 leute ausgespielt
und tik tok licon die kommentieren die
bleiben die überhaupt bis zum ende dran
oder vision die sofort weiter eine
kombination aus diesen ganzen dingen die
auf jeder plattform wird dann dazu ob
dein content peace quasi an mehr leute
ausgestrahlt wird das habe ich nicht
geschafft und es besteht auch kein
zweifel warum das so war ja gut das
alles hat aber relativ wenig mit tik tok
an sich zu tun ist eben nur eine
plattform die es ermöglicht diese videos
an eine bestimmte zielgruppe
auszustrecken aber dasselbe was
instagram macht oder youtube eine
plattform zu bieten für irgendetwas man
dann daraus macht was ich dann daraus
mache ist mein ding oder ayers oder das
von jedem der lust hat da irgendwas hoch
zu lassen ich muss dazu sagen dass ich
vielleicht auch ein bisschen wenig
motiviert war jetzt am dritten tag noch
irgendwas kasse zu machen weil ich
dachte schon alles geschafft was ich
schaffen wollte was ja auch im prinzip
so war sie doch an sich ist jetzt keine
plattform bei der ich denke wow das ist
mein ding da muss ich unbedingt viel
energie reinstecken und vielleicht hat
das ein bisschen dazu beigetragen dass
meine sachen immer schlechter wurden und
dadurch halt auch einfach weniger leute
das gesehen hat weniger leute
unterhalten als nicht unterhalten
vielleicht aber doch noch ein paar
gedanken zur plattform tik tok an sich
ja tik tok ist nur eine plattform und es
kommen selber darauf an was man daraus
macht anteil von scheiße auf tik tok ist
aber unvergleichlich hohe komplette
dauerbeschallung mit nonstop videos die
einfach durchlaufen auf zehn sekunden
gebündelte extreme mega kranker scheiß
jedes mal wenn ich dann gemacht habe
hatte ich das gefühl dass mich das
komplett in bann zieht ohne dass sich
videos gesehen habe wo ich wirklich
dachte wow das war ein hammer gutes
video diese plattform schafft einfach
ein wirklich in so eine spirale in so
einen sog zu ziehen von scheiße
und das finde ich schwierig der anteil
von bildenden content auf tik tok ist so
viel geringer als auf youtube und das
ist so viel mehr größe wirklich wenn ich
tik tok zehn minuten benutzt habe und
dass ausmache denke ich bin 50 mal
dummer entweder ich habe die plattform
komplett falsch benutzt oder nee ich
habe die plattform nicht falsch benutzt
das ist einfach so und eigentlich könnte
das ein ansporn sein dass man auf die
plattform geht und irgendetwas besser
macht als die anderen und leute
irgendwas mit gibt oder so glaube
einfach dass man damit auf anderen
plattformen besser aufgehoben ist und
das bei tik tok weiterhin die scheiße
überwiegen wird außerdem habe ich bei
tik tok das gefühl dass die plattformen
eine mischung aus dem guten von wein und
dem schlechten von knuddels ist wenn man
hier so was auf seiner startseite
vorgeschlagen bekommt nico so ein
amerikanischer youtuber hat ein super
unterhaltsames video gemacht woher
solche sachen aufzeigt und den link
findet ihr in der beschreibung guckt
euch das gerne mal content zu erstellen
ist auch noch mal was anderes als
content zu konsumieren aber ich weiß
einfach nicht ob das so das richtige für
mich ist in zukunft werde ich wenn ich
eine gute idee habe die auf 15 sekunden
super witzig ist das aufnehmen und das
auch richtig hoch lang das aber nicht so
ist werde ich mir keine ideen aus den
fingern saugen die dann halt lustig oder
überhaupt nicht lustig ist und wie hoch
war das waren meine paar gedanken zu
tecdoc ich hoffe ihr hattet viel spaß
dabei ja es ist möglich auf tik tok in
kurzer zeit erfolgreich zu werden wenn
man bereit ist sein gesicht häufig für
scheiße hinzuhalten
irgendwie macht das spaß so ein bisschen
real talk ich hoffe ihr hattet genauso
viel spaß dabei wie ich und ihr lasst
mir ein like und 1 kommentar das video
bereits ungefähr ein zehntel des
aufwands vom ersten schock lassen wir
mal in den kommentaren eure meinung zu
tik tok da ich weiß dass ein paar leute
hier tik tok benutzen und der großteil
aber wahrscheinlich nicht das letzte mal
bei der abstimmung aus und ich sage das
nicht weil ich kommentar ist nicht mehr
sondern weil es mich wirklich
interessiert was eure ganzen zu der
plattform sind so werde genauso viel
spaß dabei wenn ja lass mir leid da
abonniert damit kein video mehr verpasst
wir sehen uns am mittwoch macht dies
völlig crazy eine million aufrufe 135000
likes und es waren somit videos den spaß
nicht viel spaß bis dann